this is what it rains another peridot
and Steven episode and just as imagined
it's adorable but there is a lot of
story to this one as well which is good
I'll pretty much she's still lacked in
the bathroom and won't come out and it's
not giving any information but the only
one that seems to be able to communicate
at all with her is Steven and the gems
have to go and they they warp away to
something and the gun it says levy which
did that was really cute um in which
case a thunderstorm happens peridot
comes out thinks it's the cluster which
he says is something that's gonna
destroy everybody uh and is afraid
thinks all life is over Steven explains
it and then she decides that you know
she trusts him enough that she can
reveal all this information takes him to
the kindergarden and how he sounds funny
to say uh and pretty much shows that
this is like if I'm right a forming of a
bunch of the different shards and stuff
where there's a couple of them running
around stuff this is like one giant one
uh which is either going to be like one
big creature maybe like a bunch of these
little creatures all together uh and
it's pretty much gonna wipe out the
earth big shock and they can't stop
every parent that thinks they can stop
it but she misunderstands what Steven
knows and his abilities and such so
eventually at the end opens up to the
crystal gems and says okay let's I
something to tell you
so obviously gets home about the cluster
though it'd be great if she just tells a
big lie again but that where would that
go that'd be totally pointless um so
yeah definitely a definitely good
episode that has a has a lot of
revealing of kind of the next big story
arc II you know where before it was like
something's gonna come to earth and
destroy it what is this something who is
this something I mean now it's something
that's in the earth and we know what it
is and it's gonna eventually as she put
it hatch and they have to find a way to
stop it so you know that's cool I like
that um I like to see what this cluster
looks like um I'm hoping it's not just a
bunch of them cuz as cool as those hands
and arms and eyes and stuff are and they
are very creative uh there's only kind
of so much I can look at them some kind
of hoping it's like one big monster
that's like really cool cuz the designs
on the show are so good especially
whenever they fuse together so I'm
hoping it's kind of like that like all
the shards fusing together maybe to make
one big abomination I don't know umm but
yeah so this is uh it has those cliches
that for some reason I don't mind I
really love those cliches when someone
is afraid of something everyday cuz
they're not used to the world and then
somebody's like no this is how it works
let me show you I if done right I really
love those I think they have to be
double characters that I enjoy as well
the reasons I like the movie Thor you
know it's I've seen that a million times
but I like Thor I like that guy um and I
like seeing him interact with this stuff
and confuse stuff and I think again when
you have good characters going through
that it can become interesting you put
up with a lot more if you have good
characters you know and peridots a good
character and steve is a good character
um and yeah I like the erection I like
even the cliche of her stepping out in
the rain and enjoying it and kind of the
whimsical music going and stuff I mean
how many times will we see Matt but it's
I like peridot I like her connection
with Steven I like that they're roughly
the same size and they sort of help each
other out I like that there's more of a
connection there between those two than
like you know her in a tiara gym she
doesn't trust the other gems uh so I
really like that it's a very unlikely
connection but even at the beginning you
can kind of see it's being set up
because Steven is not that hostile
towards her even when they don't know
who she is and she's gentle with it they
see her on the screen and everything uh
he wants to talk to her and actually
gets the male life trouble but he
doesn't give up on that he's still very
nice very social he tells her to have a
nice day after she tried to kill them um
I don't know why her
particularly and maybe it's he seems to
be like that with a lot of people so I
don't know or maybe he saw something in
her that you know he thought you know
could be turned over or something nice I
don't know but uh it's really cute I
really like the connection that the two
of them have um I like the way they help
each other out I like the way they
communicate and yeah it's uh if there's
gonna be more of this I'm totally happy
with that cuz I really like and they're
kind of opposites to one is very cold
and calculating it wants to kill
everybody and stuff and the other is you
know very nice very calm very you know
welcoming so yeah I I really like that
connector I think they work very very
well
um try to think anything else yeah
camping it too much is just that we got
another art going which is really nice
another kind of main story another big
threat uh which is really cool to see I
kind of like it
you know it doesn't just stop at peridot
it's like there's something else coming
something big um but peridot plays a
bigger part than she did before so what
does she play big pretty big part before
like technically but now character wise
she plays a bigger part so yeah I'm
liking this I'm like in this direction
I'm liking these episodes tying together
and sort of having this big reveal and
this sort of this other big story going
so definitely enjoying it definitely a
big peridot peridot and Steve like I
always really liked peridot but the two
of them together especially are so much
fun and then they're just a great deal
of fun to watch so um definitely
enjoying it and we'll see you the next
one later